is something deeply sick though that's
going on now in terms of this gender
stuff that you know I used to be a Live
and Let Live type person and I really
I'm one of those people that's like hey
you're a grown adult choose a life you
want I don't care what you do you want
to you know eat badly you want to get a
bunch of surgeries like it's really up
to you but here's the problem with that
is a now with this gender activism
they're coming for kids so now we're
seeing you know targeting of children
you're seeing children on puberty
blockers you're seeing children 17 years
old not adults yet you know getting
surgeries from Physicians that are
irreversible that deform their bodies
and you're seeing something like what
you saw in this story in Ontario I don't
know if you saw the photo I'm sure you
did biological man in Canada teacher
Goes to School puts on giant prosthetic
breasts with nipples popping out and the
school is defending this guy saying well
you know this is just we're defending
gender rights as they claim so this is
now this is concerning at a different
level but because it's one thing when it
was Live and Let Live and it's another
thing when you're sending your kid to
school and this is deep sickness that's
going on now that they have to be
exposed to and institutions are just not
going to stand up for what's right
because they're more concerned with
allegiance to wokism than to allegiance
to truth so when you see that image I
mean what do you think like what what
comes to mind I'm like I I don't even
know what to say anymore I just think
we're a really lost Society at large
in uh in my fourth book in religion I
actually covered this I said we're we're
at a turning point I think right now I
don't think enough people really realize
this I I I would say it really kind of
started back in the early 2000s but
we're at a turning point right now where
we have uh like technologically and
sociological we're globalizing I always
talk about the global sexual Marketplace
but we're globalizing in a lot of other
ways and what is being exported globally
is this wokesest progressivist ideology
that this is really this you know the
all is one uh emotional emotions first
it feels before reels uh like I said
social constructionism everything that
we kind of like I mean name the the
issue that you know conservatives
generally have a problem with and I will
show you how that has been exported to
the world over the course of really the
last 30 to 40 years
um in in terms of globalizing now with
the Advent of the internet uh we can now
Mass produce that we can now uh you know
produce propaganda on a worldwide scale
whereas before we were limited to you
know by on a by country scale
um so now you see stuff like this and we
go well why are they defending this guy
this guy's clearly mentally ill do you
remember do you remember um did you ever
watch Mash back in the day when Junior
bar wasn't like yeah yeah Klinger yeah
yeah and and he was a cross dresser and
was the reason he was doing that is
because he wanted to prove that he was
insane so he could get drummed out of
the army right and build back home right
because that was a form of his
cross-dressing and transsexual that was
a form of insanity right up until a
certain point and now it's what makes
you unique now it's part of the I don't
know 72 different genders that we're all
supposed to be on board like okay let's
all play along with this narrative now
and it used to be that that was a mental
illness when did it become not a mental
illness and I would say that was
probably at the point at which
um we started mass producing and
exporting uh uh um you know militant
style feminism uh militant style woaxism
for lack of a better term just this it's
an ideology that has been sort of you
know disseminate throughout the world
well really and again this comes back to
the book I was my my fourth book
in religion I mentioned this I said we
are at a turning point right now where
our ideologies and our our memes are our
ideas our beliefs our convictions our
thoughts our our language is going to
define the realities for for generations
to come whereas before it was like we're
just kind of flying by the seat of our
pants fighting Wars and trying to make
the best of things and trying to you
know really sort of uh live the best
life that we can now and I I mentioned
this in in terms of uh like plotting the
human genome or the fact that we can do
genetic engineering very very easily
right now uh what what is right and what
is wrong what would be what is a good
use of like say genetic engineering and
what is an unethical use of genetic
engineering and so when we look at like
say the MRNA vaccine
um and we look at that we go is that a
good use of of that technology because
what it's going to do is it's going to
affect the next Generations so I put it
in these terms I said well if they ever
find a a gene or a combination of genes
that contribute to homosexuality should
we correct those
because that's an ideological question
not a technological question if we found
out hey we can turn off the gay gene and
everybody will be heterosexual should we
do that it's the same thing as like a
Down syndrome kids we can eliminate Down
syndrome because it's a genetic it's a
genetic thing if we could turn that off
and ensure that there will never be
another kid with Down Syndrome ever
again should we do that and it's the
should part it's like what's the best
practices how are we going like and
really comes down to the ethics and the
morality or whatever it is the Judgment
call of the people and the ideas at that
particular time that are going to set so
in the future like how come there's no
more you know uh homosexuals anymore how
come there's no more kids with Down
Syndrome anymore how come there's no
kids with bad eye have to wear glasses
anymore because we've corrected that
yeah it's not we're so fun this is I'm
going to steal this line from Jurassic
parking and we're so focused on on being
able to do something we never ask
ourselves should we be doing yeah and
people do that with you know people who
donate their eggs and they go through a
whole process of weeding out genetic
abnormalities and they that their goal
you know I have a friend of mine who her
mom has some sort of um abnormality that
she wanted to make sure wasn't passed
down so they went through a whole
process of how to weed that out so there
are people already who make decisions
like that about certain things and I
think the societal question becomes you
know which things are acceptable which
things are not in terms of trying to
sift out can you do it all what is
acceptable today may not be acceptable
tomorrow so it's also you know a
construct around you know what Society
deems appropriate and what those
conversations look like if you want to
watch the full episode you're going to
click right here and if you want to ask
me a question one on one you want to do
a one-on-one face time with a group of
your friends whatever you want you need
to download minute right now click right
here and let's get talking
foreign